[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias y las historias de nuestro
continente y esto es lo que veremos hoy
empezamos en eeuu porque la jueza que
kanji brawn jackson se convertirá en la
primera mujer afrodescendiente en ser
magistrada de la corte suprema de
justicia un momento histórico que hace
que el máximo tribunal esté un paso más
cerca de representar la diversidad de la
unión americana
y bajamos hasta la frontera entre méxico
y eeuu un lugar en el que regularmente
miles de personas de distintas
nacionalidades se apilan esperando
cruzar al territorio estadounidense
ahora con la invasión rusa ucrania
muchos son ucranianos que huyen de las
atrocidades pero también hay rusos que
no están de acuerdo con el accionar de
vladimir putin y luego vamos a perú que
de nuevo está en crisis también como
consecuencia de la guerra rusa en
ucrania los precios de los combustibles
están disparados en todo el mundo lo que
generó una protesta en el país andino
que derivó en un reclamo de renuncia del
presidente pedro castillo
y vamos a inmediato a eeuu para revisar
la imagen de la semana ella es que tan
jay brown jackson quien hace historia y
se convierte en la primera mujer
afrodescendiente en hacer parte de la
corte suprema de justicia de la unión
americana
jackson fue confirmada por el senado de
eeuu con el voto de tres republicanos su
nombramiento evita que el máximo órgano
judicial estadounidense gire aún más
hacia el conservadurismo aunque el
tribunal sigue teniendo una mayoría
conservadora que tanja y reemplazará al
juez stephen breyer quien se jubilará al
terminar el año legislativo jackson fue
confirmada 53 a 47 con tres votos
republicanos que se sumaron a los
demócratas además es la más joven en
hacerlo con 51 años a la parte ahora de
los nueve magistrados de cargo vitalicio
que han tenido la última palabra en
temas polémicos como el fin de la
segregación racial la legislación del
matrimonio entre parejas del mismo sexo
o el derecho a la interrupción del
embarazo
una self y que captura la historia los
emocionantes momentos después de que la
jueza que está allí brawn jackson fuera
confirmada por el senado estadounidense
asegurando su lugar como la primera
mujer negra en la corte suprema de
justicia en un tuit el presidente joe
biden celebró la confirmación como una
victoria la confirmación de la jueza
jackson fue un momento histórico para
nuestra nación hemos dado otro paso
hacia hacer que nuestra máxima corte
refleje la diversidad de eeuu ella será
una magistrada increíble y estoy honrado
de haber compartido este momento con
ella en este voto los sí son 53 los
nodos son 47 y esta nominación es
confirmada
relacionado tres republicanos se unieron
a los demócratas para sellar el triunfo
en un voto de 53 a 47 durante sus
audiencias de confirmación la jueza de
la corte de apelaciones enfrentó
cuestionamientos por los clientes que
tomó mientras fue defensora pública
algunos serán sospechosos de terrorismo
de guantánamo lo que llevó a los
republicanos a acusarlo de ser laxa con
el crimen 115 personas han sido
magistrados de la corte suprema durante
sus 233 años de historia jackson será la
sexta mujer y la tercera persona
afrodescendiente para ella la
oportunidad es el resultado de décadas
de progreso
estoy aquí en los hombros de
generaciones de estadounidenses que
nunca estuvieron ni siquiera cerca a
este tipo de oportunidad desde mis
abuelos que sólo tuvieron una educación
escuela pero le inculcaron a mis padres
la importancia de aprender y mis padres
los primeros en sus familias en ir a la
universidad
la confirmación de jackson llena una
promesa de campaña importante de joe
biden la primera mujer afro en la corte
suprema poco después de haber llevado a
la vicepresidenta a la casa blanca
y sigamos allí en washington porque el
capitolio tiene otro problema un zorro
atacó un congresista por california el
animal fue sacrificado posteriormente
porque tenía rabia también sus crías
veamos más en el siguiente informe el
paso del zorro es la escena del crimen
de eeuu rápidamente se convirtió en el
canino más buscado en washington en este
explícito vídeo el sospechoso acecha el
capitolio los alrededores del senado y
la cámara de representantes- esperando
para saltar sobre el congresista a mi
vera
sentí que algo se abalanzaba sobre mí
por detrás pensé que era un perro
pequeño o algo así
me lancé con mi paraguas y descubrí que
no es un perro es un zorro
el político demócrata fue solo una de
las aproximadamente 12 víctimas del
zorro esta mujer también fue presa de
sus trucos la mordedura del animal puede
ser una lesión grave y en algunos casos
transmitir la rabia
después de una cacería que se prolongó
durante varias horas la policía local
finalmente pudo capturar a la astuta
criatura
sabes mucha gente ha estado preguntando
es éste el único zorro esperamos que sea
el único zorro pero hay otras trampas en
el área así que si hay otros zorros con
suerte caerán en ellas aunque los zorros
urbanos si están presentes en algunas
ciudades de eeuu este tipo de
comportamiento agresivo no es común
como consecuencia de la invasión rusa
ucrania millones de personas son ahora
desplazadas algunas de ellas han llegado
hasta américa las autoridades de
migración en méxico estiman que cerca de
10 mil personas han llegado a este país
desde que inició la guerra entre rusia y
ucrania diariamente llegan a tijuana en
la frontera con san diego california en
eeuu cerca de 300 migrantes buscando
asilo político en ese país voluntarios y
familiares ucranianos que viven en la
unión americana se han acercado a la
frontera para ayudar con alimentos
cobijas y medicamentos a las familias
que están en albergues veamos más en el
siguiente informe de nuestro equipo en
terreno
será artista es una madre ucraniana que
huyó con su esposo e hijo de 10 años
tras la guerra con rusia atravesó más de
5 países hasta llegar a mexico para
conseguir asilo político en eeuu junto
con su familia sara de sobreviviente por
segunda vez de un conflicto bélico el
primero lo vivió hace ocho años en
tumbas
en europa ya no hay espacio las personas
ya no tienen donde dormir o donde vivir
está lleno y me duele cuando mi hijo me
pregunta mami si la guerra comenzó ya
entonces voy a morir es terrible eso mi
único sueño como madre es pedir que mi
hijo pueda vivir maría es una joven de
20 años viajó sola estaba a punto de
graduarse de la carrera de computación y
dejó a su madre en ucrania para reunirse
con su hermana
yo estaba en polonia por una semana
aproximadamente estuve también en
alemania luego viajé a méxico en cancún
y finalmente aquí estoy
quiero reunirme con mi hermana que está
en eeuu sólo quiero estar con él
fuera del albergue instalado en la
unidad deportiva benito juárez el centro
de tijuana familiares de ucranianos
intentan reunirse con los suyos como
víctor desde hace 8 años vive en nueva
york' su hermano y su cuñada perdieron
todo tras la guerra
en tanto es mi hermana trabaja en un
consultorio dental mi cuñado y mi
hermano tenían un taller de autos
desafortunadamente el negocio quebró yo
solo espero que el proceso sea rápido me
gustaría que las autoridades agilicen el
trámite y ayuden a que las familias
ucranianas se reúnan nuevamente
cada hora son transportados de este
albergue cerca de 100 ucranianos al paso
internacional de cruce entre tijuana y
san diego para ser entrevistados por las
autoridades norteamericanas adultos y
niños se esperan encontrar en un nuevo
país la esperanza de vivir en paz en
tiempos de guerra
y vamos ahora al sur del continente a
perú porque su presidente pedro castillo
atraviesa la peor crisis política y
social desde su llegada al poder hace
apenas nueve meses y que ha tenido
varias crisis al estar al borde de la
destitución dos veces en el congreso
esta vez una huelga de transportistas
que empezó en rechazo al aumento del
precio del combustible que se registra a
nivel mundial debido a la invasión rusa
ucrania derivó en un reclamo por su
renuncia y para exigir que cumpla sus
promesas de campaña lo que significa que
ciudadanos que lo apoyaban anteriormente
le han dado la espalda
deja vu en perú el presidente pedro
castillo enfrenta una nueva crisis esta
vez por cuenta de más de dos semanas de
protestas que iniciaron en rechazo al
aumento del precio de los combustibles y
derivaron en un grito de rechazo a su
gestión por parte de los mismos que lo
llevaron al poder lo acusan de no
cumplir sus promesas de campaña y actuar
según ellos contra el neoliberalismo
para cumplir sus promesas de campaña que
no tenga miedo
en el modelo económico porque la gente
está en un momento de porque las
familias están aguantando una crisis que
es internacional sí pero que tienen que
resolverse con medidas de gobierno una
área pero importa la mayor parte de su
petróleo por lo que el aumento en el
precio del combustible generado por la
invasión rusa ucrania golpeó su economía
que apenas se recuperaba del impacto de
la pandemia y los confinamientos contra
el hobbit 19 la inflación de perú en
marzo fue la más alta en 26 años según
el instituto nacional de estadísticas e
informática los más afectados fueron los
alimentos que subieron un 9,54 por
ciento desde 2021 según el banco central
de perú
el 28 de marzo un grupo de trabajadores
del transporte y del sindicato de
camioneros convocó a un paro general
para exigir una disminución en el precio
de la gasolina el gobierno peruano había
logrado un acuerdo con los
transportistas para que se levantaran
las protestas luego de que castillo
hiciera algunas concesiones como reducir
los impuestos al combustible y aumentar
el salario mínimo a mil 25 soles
aproximadamente
280 dólares un kilo de pan cuesta un
dólar 48 una docena de huevos
1 con 58 y la mayoría de los peruanos
pertenece a la economía informal pero
alimento de nuevo el descontento al
imponer un toque de queda ahora los
señalan de tomar decisiones improvisadas
y venezuela es un país conocido por su
éxito en los concursos de belleza ahora
las personas con síndrome de dawn a paso
lento están teniendo más oportunidades
en escenarios y pasarelas nuestra
corresponsal en caracas daniela zambrano
nos cuenta la historia de dos de ellas
jessica jacinto se prepara para su
primera pasarela en traje de novia en la
ciudad de valència es la sensación tras
bastidores
su condición de síndrome de dawn no fue
una limitante para alcanzar sus sueños y
convertirse en modelo
[Música]
el reconocido diseñador venezolano wing
molina confiesa que al principio tuvo
miedo pero la reacción de sus clientes
al ver a jessica vestir sus diseños no
solo se tradujo en halagos y mensajes de
respaldo también tuvo un impacto
positivo en sus ventas me llegaron
muchos más clientes o sea ni siquiera
con las misses nada
la reacción fue tan tan grande
yanira su madre cuenta que el camino no
ha sido fácil mucho se habla de la
inclusión y la diversidad en venezuela
pero en la práctica son pocos quienes
están dispuestos a arriesgarse y dar la
primera oportunidad
un desfile de moda que va a haber dentro
de poco que si podía jessica participar
me dijeron
no no puede participar porque no llena
los requisitos de medir 175 a más de 170
kilómetros en la capital venezolana y
sabe la otra joven de 21 años con la
misma condición adelanta su rutina en el
gimnasio también sueña con ser modelo
aunque hace más de una década se dedica
a la gimnasia artística
sólo vas un cromosoma extra para modelar
las conciencias y su slogan en redes
sociales es decir mi vida y segura de sí
misma conoce sus cualidades y no duda en
demostrar las con total espontaneidad
de vuelta a valencia cae la noche e
inicia el desfile yanira contempla con
orgullo el debut de su hija jessica
entre en escena y se escuchan los
aplausos estos de admiración por una
modelo que comienza a dejar huella en un
mundo que lucha por la inclusión
[Aplausos]
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa recuerden que pueden
seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas en la
producción estuvo giovanni agudelo sigan
viendo más en france 24 y france24
puntocom
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el pro